non politiques les ong développent des
stratégies d' influence qui privilégie
l'émotionnel sur le rationnel le
sectarisme de la majorité d'entre elles
les amènent à des interprétations qui
exclut toute pensée ou comportements
n'allant pas dans leur sens et leur
condition n'hésitant pas à tordre les
faits et à utiliser tous les moyens pour
imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petit coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent à la
pelle en soi vient des guignols
aujourd'hui une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
les premiers résultats sont attendus
dans la nuit ou l'ouzbékistan votaient
ce dimanche pour élire son futur
président grand favori du scrutin
l'actuel chef de l'état schaaf 4000 cf
face à lui quatre autres candidats en
lice la commission électorale c'était
avec le poisson dit pour cent de
participation au vote
[Musique]
les opérations aériennes se succèdent au
tigré gris bombardements en une semaine
l'aviation et you qu'elle a mené ce
dimanche de nouvelles frappes cette fois
ci dans l'ouest et le nord de cette
région guerre à les forces
gouvernementales tentent de déloger les
autorités
dissidente issus du sondé les rations
jeux peuvent que le tigré
cinq ans après le démantèlement de la
jungle de calais la gestion de la
frontière est toujours dans l'impasse
des centaines de personnes sont toujours
entassés dans des campements de fortune
elles attendent et espèrent pouvoir
traverser la manche londres souhaite
durcir
dil ses relations avec paris sur le
sujet sont tondus
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
si son premier mandat a été marqué par
des réformes libérales comme l'abolition
du travail forcé ses détracteurs
l'accusent d'avoir renoué avec des
méthodes autoritaires l'eau président de
l'ouzbékistan shavkat mirziyoyev devrait
être réélu pour un second mandat plus de
70% des électeurs se sont déplacés dans
les bureaux de vote ce dimanche face à
lui quatre autres candidats les premiers
résultats pourraient tomber dans la nuit
demain au plus tard walid bey l'année
il est arrivé tout sourire et en famille
chef 4 mirziyoyev montre l'exemple face
caméra en temps de pandémie de kovy 19
et surtout de campagne électorale
l'actuel président ouzbek ne souhaitent
commettre aucun faux pas les prochaines
heures seront décisives
shafqat mirzaïev vie cinq nouvelles
années au pouvoir pour répondre aux
attentes des 34 millions d'habitants
dans l'ancienne république soviétique
les principaux problèmes se situent dans
les régions pas dans la capitale dans la
capitale tout va plus ou moins bien les
gens l'eau le gaz l'électricité dans les
régions malheureusement il ya un manque
de tout cela
notre président a longtemps été aux
côtés d' islam karimov et pour cette
raison il a appris les méthodes pour
gouverner le pays c'est pourquoi j'ai
voté pour le président marianne
shafqat mirziyoyev 64 ans intronisé
président par intérim à la mort d'islam
karimov avait obtenu en 2016 dans la
foulée la confiance de la population par
les urnes après 25 années sous la
présidence controversée de karimov
l'ancien premier ministre a très vite
entrepris des mesures saluées par la
communauté internationale comme l'arrêt
du travail forcé dans les champs de
coton qui a libéré des milliers
d'enfants
début septembre le congrès du mouvement
des entrepreneurs et des hommes
d'affaires organisée par le parti
libéral démocrate
adoubé shavkat mirziyoyev pour un ultime
quinquennat le chef d'état par très
favoris selon les derniers échos venus
de tâches 4
les conférenciers ont noté que le
candidat mir au f à de nombreuses années
d'expérience en leadership et apporté
une grande contribution développement de
notre pays et à la prospérité de notre
peuple des programmes à vocation sociale
ont été mises en oeuvre il a été noté
qu'une grande attention est accordée au
développement de la science de
l'éducation de la santé de la culture et
des arts des médias de masse des sports
l'actuel président est aussi félicité
pour l'ouverture du pays aux touristes
désirant visiter l'ancien joyau de la
route de la soie
mais ces derniers mois les médias
indépendants ont été les seuls à
critiquer les ambitions autoritaire
gouvernement dans le domaine politique
et de la presse
si le soutien mutuel des médias en
particulier des médias sur internet se
renforce je pense qu'il sera possible
d'atteindre le niveau de liberté
d'expression dont nous rêvons et que
nous nous efforçons d'avoir dans notre
patrie
si shafqat mirziyoyev est élu pour un
second mandat l'homme sera attendu au
tournant et sommet de poursuivre sa
politique réformatrice
l'ouzbékistan pays où la croissance
économique a été douloureusement impacté
par la pandémie de kovy 19 en ligne de
mire également l'augmentation du prix du
gaz qui a poussé le peuple dans la rue
l'année dernière
les combats s'intensifient au tigré chic
l'aviation éthiopienne a mené ce
dimanche de nouvelles frappes sur cette
région dissidente hui bombardements
aériens au total en une semaine les vols
humanitaires sont suspendus à la
situation est alarmante pour la
population
l'onu estime à environ 400 milles le
nombre de personnes proches de la famine
grâce d'ailleurs
des convois humanitaires attaqué par des
résidents locaux en colère contre les
tigres et 1 et leurs attaques les
frappes aériennes régulières de l'armée
éthiopienne un contexte qui a forcé en
vols humanitaires des nations unies a
renoncé à son atterrissage dans la
région du tigré l' escalade des combats
est si préoccupante en grande partie
parce qu'elles sapent les efforts qui
sont essentiels pour assurer la sécurité
des civils et apporter une aide
humanitaire aux éthiopiens qui en ont le
plus besoin c'est pourquoi nous avons
demandé instamment à toutes les parties
de mettre immédiatement fin aux
hostilités et au gouvernement éthiopien
et au front de libération du peuple du
tigré d'entamer des négociations sans
condition préalable en vue d'un
cessez-le-feu durable des combats qui se
poursuivent avec des soldats du
gouvernement mais aussi des milices
formées à la hâte qui souhaite à tout
prix en découdre avec les forces du
tigre et
le 22 juillet j'ai été recruté pour un
entraînement militaire après avoir reçu
une autre formation de base qui a duré
quinze jours ils ont dit que je n'avais
nulle part où aller
comptez était envahi la milice locale et
les forces de défense nous ont forcés à
nous déployer dans la région d'afar ils
nous ont dit vous serez de retour dans
les dix à quinze jours après avoir
accompli au service certains d'entre
nous ont fait part de leurs
préoccupations mais personne n'a semblé
nous écouter nous avons servi sans
aucune compensation alors que les
soldats du gouvernement eux sont payés
nous avons continué à servir et pendant
les combats qui ont lieu les 10 et 11
octobre nous nous sommes rendus toute la
semaine les combats se sont étendus aux
régions voisines et notamment la région
d'afar où de nombreux habitants pensent
que l'onu et la communauté
internationale se trompent
les gens qui nous font du mal sont ceux
qui reçoivent du soutien paris-xi
une guerre entre les forces éthiopiennes
contre les tigres et un long temps
rennes du pouvoir des hostilités qui ont
été lancés en novembre 2020 par le
premier ministre habib ahmed lauréat du
prix nobel de la paix 2010 9 pourchasser
les membres du tplf front de libération
du peuple du tigré des combats qui
continuent à se poursuivre aujourd'hui
et qui ont causé le déplacement de
centaines de milliers de personnes la
population est majoritairement les
enfants souffrent de malnutrition sévère
les médecins me disent qu'elle est mal
nourrie nous étions en train d'errer
dans le désert et ma fille était malade
et j'étais terrifiée pour elle une horde
de l'ethiopie où la communication est
totalement rompu rend la situation
difficile à appréhender de l'extérieur
mais l'onu de son côté continue
d'alerter sur la situation humanitaire
dramatique qui sévit dans la région les
deux vols par semaine vers le tigre et
sont temporairement suspendus pour
préserver la sécurité du personnel
embarqué un nouvel la mobilisation des
pros armés dans les rues de khartoum au
soudan
les principaux axes routiers pont de la
capitale ont été bloqués les forces de
l'ordre ont fait usage de gaz
lacrymogènes pour disperser les
protestataires
protestataires qui réclament un
gouvernement militaire voilà plusieurs
jours que les tensions font à leur
comble avec les partisans d'un transfert
complet du pouvoir cette fois ci au
civil des démonstrations de force dans
la rue qui ne devrait pas pour autant
selon les experts accélérer la
transition après tondre règne d'omar el
béchir
est la police ougandaise évoque un acte
de terrorisme antérieure au lendemain de
l'explosion dont la capitale kampala
frêle a fait un mort et plusieurs
blessés dans un restaurant populaire
trois personnes ont fait exploser un
colis ci après avoir quitté les lieux un
engin explosif sommaire contenant des
clous et des morceaux de métal l'attaqué
s'est produite dans la soirée ou qu'une
indication pour le moment sur l'identité
ou sur les motivations des auteurs
présumés
les circuits indique clairement que
trois hommes déguisés en clients sont
arrivés au point de restauration qui
appartient à loulé samuel vers 20h30
après avoir quitté les lieux les trois
suspects ont finalement fait exploser
l'engin explosif improvisé qui a causé
des blessures à quatre victimes au total
israël annonce la construction de plus
de 1300 nouveaux logements dans des
colonies juives de cisjordanie occupée
logements qui doivent s'ajouter aux
quelque deux mille annoncées en août par
les autorités qui doivent obtenir cette
semaine en feu vert définitif du
ministère de la défense le renforcement
de la présence juive est essentiel dont
la vision sioniste a indiqué le ministre
de la construction au moins six cent
soixante quinze mille israéliens
habitent aujourd'hui dans des colonies à
jérusalem-est et en cisjordanie occupée
des colonies contraire au droit
international et qui provoque la colère
des plus de trois millions de
palestiniens qui y vivent
israël qui a normalisé ses relations
avec plusieurs pays arabes le guide
suprême iranien lors demande aujourd'hui
de revenir sur leur décision
en 2000 ventes sous l'impulsion du
président américain de l'époque donald
trump les émirats arabes unis bahreïn le
soudan et le maroc signé les accords
d'abraham grosse erreur et pêcher estime
ali khamenei c'est l'unité des musulmans
qui est en jeu selon lui il s'exprimait
à l'occasion de la conférence
internationale de l'unité islamique on
écoute
de morceaux mais massa l'eiffel estime
le principal indicateur de l'unité des
musulmans et la question de la palestine
la question de la palestine est un
indicateur si l'unité des musulmans et
réaliser la question de la palestine
sera certainement résolu de la meilleure
façon
plus nous prenons au sérieux la question
de la palestine afin de rétablir les
droits du peuple palestinien plus nous
nous rapprocherons de l'unité des
musulmans
[Musique]
malheureusement certains gouvernements
ont fait une erreur dans la récente
normalisation des relations avec israël
ils ont fait une grosse erreur et ont
péché et ont normalisé leurs relations
avec le régime sioniste usurpateur et
oppresseur
c'est un mouvement d'unités anti
islamique ils doivent revenir de cette
voie ils doivent se racheter pour cette
grosse erreur
il ya cinq ans jour pour jour été
démantelé la jungle de calais ce vaste
camp de migrants au nord de la france
dix mille personnes s'y étaient
installés vivent dans des conditions
déplorables des images fortes
illustrations de l'ampleur de la crise
migratoire en europe le récit de martial
payant
une distribution de flyers n'ont pas
pour promouvoir une festivité mais pour
prévenir les migrants que la jungle de
calais va être définitivement démantelé
on nous a donné ce signe on ne sait pas
vraiment ce qu'il va se passer demain on
m'a dit que la jungle ce sera terminé ce
lundi
à l'aube du lundi 24 octobre 2016 et
sont une dizaine de milliers à vivre
dans ce bidonville situé à 400 mètres du
port de calais
ces migrants proviennent majoritairement
d'afrique d'afghanistan et de syrie et
rêve de rejoindre le royaume uni
après plusieurs démantèlement partiel
qui se sont soldées par des échecs
françois hollande promet en 2016 de
reloger les occupants dans 80 centres
d'accueil aux quatre coins de l'hexagone
dimanche soir quelques affrontements ont
lieu entre la police et les migrants
opposés à la fermeture du camp
mais les choses rentrent dans l'ordre le
lundi matin il est l'heure de s'en aller
[Musique]
les migrants attendent dans un sas
gigantesque le bus qui les transportera
vers un avenir incertain en moins d'une
journée
2318 migrants déjà été transférés 24
heures plus tard le chiffre a presque
doublé
ce soir si on ajoute les chiffres d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui
4014 personnes ont été mises à l'abri
depuis ce bâtiment son hangar devenu le
sas 4014 personnes ont été mises à
l'abri soit des migrants majeurs qui ont
rejoint les centres d'accueil
d'orientation soit des mineurs qui ont
été mis à l'abri au niveau du centre
d'accueil provisoire au sein du camp de
la honte au cinquième jour les derniers
migrants retranchés dans le coin école
du camp sont évacués le bidonville est
petit à petit réduit en miettes
cinq ans plus tard la jungle n'existe
plus mais quelques dizaines de migrants
continuent de s'y réfugier les
campements sauvages sont
systématiquement détruits une politique
qui vise à dissuader les migrants de
rejoindre le royaume uni pourtant ils
n'ont jamais été aussi nombreux à tenter
de traverser la manche que pendant
l'année 2021 ils sont plus de 18000 à
avoir rejoint le royaume uni depuis
janvier dernier et président de
l'association france rentre a terni t
pierre-henri plaide pour des voies de
migration légale écouté
il y à a calé un certain nombre de
jeunes gens dont la famille et de
l'autre capter et donc il fout des voies
de migration légale moi je ne suis pas
en train de dire qu'il faut ouvrir les
portes
de la grande bretagne elle ne le fera
pas mais je dis qu'il faut des voix une
migration légale
sans ça les ont fait le jeu des passeurs
on ne résout rien du tout on ne résout
rien a donné une mission à la police qui
est en permanence de déloger les
migrants ça n'a pas fait reculer le
front national ça n'empêche pas les gens
de venir
ça enchérit le coût du passage donc il y
à une solution qui existe est une
solution de voies de migration légale
pour la première fois depuis le 30
septembre le taux d'incidence en france
repasse au-dessus du seuil d'alert de 50
pour cent mille habitants
50,9 précisément selon les chiffres
publiés par ce que tu existes france
6291 nouveau 4 qu'ovide ont été recensés
ces dernières 24 heures c'est 28 % de
plus que samedi dernier en revanche le
nombre de personnes hospitalisées reste
en baisse avec 6348 patients dont un peu
plus de 1000 en réanimation 23 nouveaux
décès ont également été enregistré
samedi c'est dans ce contexte que les
députés ont adopté cette semaine en
première lecture le projet de loi
vigilance sanitaire il prévoit notamment
de prolonger le recours aux passes annie
terre jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 un texte
loin de faire l'unanimité les débats ont
été houleux les sénateurs se
prononceront à leur tour à ce jeudi
estelle phare
le texte vigilance sanitaire c'est la
boîte à outils de l'exécutif pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de kovy de 19 parmi
les outils validée par les députés
l'article 2 adopté in extremis par les
députés 74 voix pour et 73 contre il
permet donc à l'exécutif de prolonger
l'obligation du pass sanitaires pour les
huit prochains mois et en enjambant la
présidentielle même chose pour le régime
de sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
prolongé donc jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022
ils permettent au gouvernement de
déclencher à tout moment en fonction de
la situation sanitaire et des mesures
restrictives couvre-feu confinement ou
simplement des limitations de
circulation des mesures qui pourraient
coincer chez les sénateurs d'ailleurs
gérard larcher a prévenu il n'est pas
question de donner un blanc-seing
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 il faut que ça
soit sous le contrôle du parlement ça
veut dire que en février nous devront
débattre à nouveau de la poursuite du
processus de sortie de l'urgence c'est
une atteinte aux libertés individuelles
et collectives
ça ne peut se faire que sous le contrôle
du parlement dans une démocratie
parlementaire
parmi les amendements adoptés à
l'assemblée celui qui porte sur la
connaissance du statut vaccinal des
élèves par les directeurs
d'établissement l'exécutif il voit une
façon je cite d'organiser des conditions
d'enseignement afin de prévenir les
risques de propagation du virus une
mesure qui déchaîne les passions car
elle menace le secret médical selon
certains comme le chef de file des
sénateurs socialistes
ça ne me paraît pas être le rôle d'un
enseignant que de contrôler la situation
sanitaire des enfants je suis très
réservé ce projet de loi arrivera entre
les mains des sénateurs le jeudi 28
octobre prochain la république en marche
ne pouvant compter que sur une vingtaine
d'élus les débats s'annoncent
mouvementées l opa sanitaire 1 continue
de nous mobiliser contre lui nouvelle
manifestation hier en france pour le 15e
samedi consécutif protestations aussi
contre la baisse du pouvoir d'achat avec
en ligne de mire la hausse des prix de
l'énergie malgré l'aide promise par le
gouvernement une indemnité inflation de
100 euros le prix du carburant à
l'origine du mouvement des gilet jaune
il était dont la rue lui aussi hier
hélène masquelier
le retour des gis les jaunes et bien
actée ce samedi encore ils étaient
plusieurs centaines à défiler dans les
rues de paris un nouveau souffle porté
par la protestation contre la hausse des
prix du carburant un combat qu'il mène
depuis 2018 et qui avait été à la base
de leur mouvement dans la capitale
un défilé dans le calme mais une colère
toujours bien présente
qu'ils arrêtent de nous taxer qu'ils
arrêtent de se gaver sur des produits de
première nécessité indispensable pour
l'ensemble des français on nous
rackettent ans en nous prenant toujours
notre argent et on se demande en
derrière comment on pourrait faire pour
leur permettre de diminuer un petit peu
lent charge en leur reversant notre
argent alors c'est un comble après une
chute des prix de l'énergie en 2020 ces
tarifs connaissent un fort rebond depuis
l'été pour étouffer la colère qui couve
le gouvernement a décidé de sortir son
chéquier
[Applaudissements]
nous allons décider d'une sorte d'
indemnité inflation de 100 euros qui
sera versée aux français qui gagnent
moins de 2000 euros net par mois une
aide qui concernerait près de 38
millions de personnes mais la somme est
jugée dérisoire par de nombreux
protestataires
le chèque de 100 euros c'est juste pour
endormir les gens parce que si vous
divisez 100 euros par part 12 mois ça
fait quoi à 8 euros au bout de votre
plein donc c'est pas c'est pas suffisant
100 euros vous retirer les taxes ça veut
dire qu'on à 39 euros sur une année ma
décomptés par jour ce que ça fait c'est
des miettes et puis toute façon faut
arrêter de se [ __ ] de notre gueule
c'est pas les 100 euros qui vont changer
quoi que ce soit dans la vie des gens
retour aux sources du mouvement aux
abords des ronds-points également les
gilet jaune reprennent timidement place
dans le paysage urbain et se mêle
désormais aux antilles passe et autres
salariés suspendu car non vaccinés avec
un message inchangé ou presque j'étais
déjà sur les ronds points en 2010 et
avec les mêmes mêmes revendications a
dit renée en plus grave beaucoup plus
grave aujourd'hui parce que
ça continue en fait ça s'arrête jamais
quoi j'aurais même politique et
donc on est là une telle en 2018 et on
sera encore là un fossé toujours plus
large qui sépare le peuple
contestataires du gouvernement une
colère populaire que redoute la majorité
à six mois de l'élection présidentielle
le retour des gis les jaunes et
surveiller comme le lait sur le feu par
l'exécutif avec la crainte que le
mouvement reprenne la même ampleur qu il
y a trois ans
à les états unis commémorer et vendredi
sa lutte contre les violences policières
au delà du mouvement black l'animateur
le sujet hautement explosif dans le pays
continue d'alimenter l'actualité et les
débats politiques
la correspondance à washington de thomas
bonnet
la question des violences policières est
un sujet récurrent est particulièrement
inflammable aux états unis au delà de la
très médiatisée affaire georges floyd il
y à une réalité qui est très
certainement sous-estimé
une récente étude affirme que les
statistiques officielles en matière de
morts engendrés par la police est très
nettement inférieur à la réalité selon
les données de cette étude entre 1980 et
2000 18 30 mille huit cents personnes
seraient mortes suite à des violences
policières alors que les statistiques
officielles elle n'en relèvent qu'à
peine la moitié comme le montre notre
analyse la violence mortelle de la
police et les grandes disparités
raciales dans cette violence sont
restées largement inchangées ou ont
augmenté depuis 1990 alors cette étude a
des relents politiques puisque ses
auteurs se disent par exemple favorable
aux coupes budgétaires engagées dans les
services de police de plusieurs grandes
villes américaines define the police
c'est d'ailleurs un slogan récurrent au
sein du mouvement black like the matters
alors que pour d'autres justement ce
sont ces réductions budgétaires qui ont
conduit à une augmentation du nombre de
crimes aux états unis le sujet est donc
éminemment politique avec toujours cette
fracture entre démocrates et
républicains
et il faut d'ailleurs se souvenait du
clip de campagne publié l'an passé par
les équipes de joe biden et deux
camarades
mais les promesses du candidat byden se
sont heurtés à la réalité politique du
congrès américain faute d'accord le
projet de réforme de la police n'a pas
abouti démocrates et républicains se
rejetant la faute de manière regrettable
les sénateurs républicains ont rejeté
deux modestes réforme que même l'ancien
président avait soutenu tout en refusant
d'agir sur des points clés que même les
forces de l'ordre étaient prêtes à
discuter le crime va continuer
d'augmenter pendant que la sécurité
diminue et plus d'officiers de police
vont quitter leur poste parce que mes
partenaires de négociation ont quitté la
table plus d'un an après les larges
manifestations dans le cadre du
mouvement black like the matters les
militants restent donc à pleinement
mobilisée pour tenter d'influencer la
politique menée par joe biden mais faute
de consensus le locataire de la maison
blanche a une marge de manoeuvre très
faible sur cette question avec le risque
de décevoir une partie de son électorat
facebook est à nouveau dans la tourmente
le réseau social est engluée dans une
série de révélations concernant
notamment la gestion de la
désinformation sur la plateforme ce
vendredi de nouvelles informations ont
été publiées par plusieurs médias
américains les précisions de guy marrot
6 es ce que vous avez déjà entendu
parler de carole smith une mère de
famille de caroline du nord sur facebook
elle s'intéresse à la politique au
christianisme et elle suit des pages
comme fox news ou celles liées à donald
trump bref l'archétype de la
conservatrice américaine sauf que carole
smith et bien elles n'existent pas en
réalité son identité ne se limite qu'à
un faux compte facebook créée de toutes
pièces en 2019 par un chercheur de la
firme américaine l'objectif étudier le
rôle du réseau social dans la
désinformation et la polarisation
politique des utilisateurs de la
plateforme notamment via son site deux
recommandations en clair voir comment
facebook oriente ses utilisateurs en
fonction de leur profil et là le constat
a été sans appel alors même que carole
smith ne montre pas d'intérêt
particulier pour les théories du complot
l'algorithme de facebook lui suggère de
rejoindre des groupes liés à cuny et ce
à seulement deux jours après la création
du faux profils pire alors même que
carole smith ou plutôt son faux comptes
ignore ses recommandations en l'espace
d'une semaine elle est envahie de
suggestions pour des quantités de pages
et de groupes qui violent les propres
règles de la plateforme sur la haine en
ligne et la désinformation un comble les
conclusions de cette expérience ont été
baptisés le voyage de carole vertus aux
jeunes elle figure parmi les documents
qui ont été fournies aux autorités
américaines par la lanceuse d'alert
française à ogden une ancienne employée
de facebook depuis un mois le contenu de
ces documents que certains médias
américains ont pu consulter alimente les
facebook files et illustre le lien tout
particulier qu'entretient facebook avec
la désinformation sur sa propre
plateforme et le voyage de carole vers
kyo et note que les médias ont révélé ce
vendredi en est une parfaite
illustration
l'ensemble des recherches a montré que
facebook poussé certains utilisateurs
dans des terriers de lapins des chambres
d'échos de plus en plus étroites où
prospèrent de violentes théorie du
complot les personnes radicalisé par
cette terrier de lapin ne constitue
qu'une petite partie du nombre total
d'utilisateurs mais à l'échelle de
facebook cela peut représenter des
millions d'individus or il semblerait
que malgré ces résultats alarmants
facebook n'est pas agi à la hauteur de
la menace le géant américain aurait bien
identifier le problème sauf que selon
les facebook files la firme serait non
seulement incapable de gérer
correctement les flux de désinformation
mais surtout réticente à trop intervenir
un avis partagé par plusieurs employés
ou ex-employés de la plate forme dont
français ça hogan elle même vous savez
la lanceuse d'alert de qui tout est
parti et bien voici ce qu'elle déclarait
au début de la faire facebook a compris
que s'ils changent l algorithme pour le
rendre plus sûres les gens passeraient
moins de temps sur le site ils
cliqueraient sur moins de publicité il
générerait moins d'argent moralité si
comme le dit l'adage le crime ne paie
pas le mensonge lui semble bien être
plus rentable surtout lorsqu'il se
répand en quelques clics et c'est la fin
de cette édition se retrouve dans une
trentaine de minutes pour un nouveau
journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
de coeur des femmes est plus fragile que
celui des hommes en france c'est 200
femmes par jour